[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
ryan's here with me hello
hello hello hello oh man
this year's almost over this is uh
we have a i think not many shows left of
this year but uh
then it's the the year that's supposed
to be better
2021 it's got to be better it has to be
yeah it'll take a little time but not
much
not as much time it's just good to know
you know when you're sitting here it's
like you're in limbo
you're just like uh these last eight
months or whatever and you're like oh so
when is
when are we gonna we don't know nothing
we have no idea when this is gonna end
and now with the vaccine you're like oh
okay so this is the beginning of you
know the
uh yeah it's starting to feel like the
beginning of the end yeah
you know that's good hey thanks for uh
listening out there i say it all the
time but i
really appreciate it uh and listen if
you uh
you could do us a big favor it does the
pod of favor go drop a a rating
or and a review for us over at apple
podcasts i'm sure many of you have and
but if you haven't
it helps significantly there's some kind
of
algorithm that they use um if you're
listening there or have the app
um stop what you're doing and go support
the show on you know youtube
it takes a couple of seconds it really
helps everything we're doing here so
you know you just write a review do a
rating and
um spread the word as always you know
there's so many podcasts and things out
there so if you're enjoying this we want
to keep doing it we love doing it and uh
it helps and we're trying to grow an
audience here so
if you're digging it and uh big thanks
to nathan fillion from last week great
episode
good editing job he was he was fun good
stash he had a great stash good stash
high def stash high def stash he had a
really good
camera and uh yeah he had it all worked
the lighting was great i mean i think
ours is good
he went above and beyond it's cinema
yeah yeah i think that's it when it
comes to subscribing our socials
here's the handles follow us like things
mention things what is it ryan at inside
of you pod on twitter
inside of your podcast on instagram and
facebook
youtube.com inside of you with michael
rosenbaum subscribe
and write the reviews uh also the store
got a new product coming soon
can't tell you what it is but head over
to the inside of you online store
grab a 15 off you know what for the
holidays
hell with it 20 off everything
oh man just use the discount code inside
of you 20.
get it while last i'm just gonna put it
for a few days probably tuesday and
wednesday
um but uh you know got wine glasses and
uh we got mugs
autographed mugs we got uh shirts and
hats just a bunch of stuff and it's
really groovy
and that's pretty much where we're at
here um
the album uh rob and i are are making
uh the band is called sunspin it's my
new band where
at the very end of recording we've
really been busting our ass we've been
playing stage it's
thank you all the patrons out there and
everybody who have supported the band
and
uh we're really stoked i really think we
i think we went above and beyond we
really worked hard and
uh these feel full produced there's
great melodies harmonies and i just
really love the album i'm really excited
about it i don't expect to be a rock
star or anything i just want to do it
because i love it but
i'm like man this is like i'm proud of
this [ __ ] it's good to be proud it's
good to not
think i got to be great at this but i
think it's pretty great
and it's good to have made something
this year yeah man it's like a tough
year too and you make an album and you
do something and you feel productive i i
think that's uh
that's really important and thanks to
westwood one for the support and thanks
again
for uh all the love and support and
extra support by my patrons
if you want to join patreon it's it's
wonderful it's patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n.com
inside or maybe inside of you and i
i always text you back right when you
become a a patron
and uh there's lots of great things on
there take a look there's a bunch of
tiers and
zooms and whatever there's just stuff
that's it we got a great guest today
i've been trying to get her for a long
time and you think ryan
that the girl who played lois lane on
smallville would be an easy guess that
would be an easy get
i got everybody else but she you know
we're friends but
um and it's funny because we uh we talk
about it on the pot
we weren't like we didn't work together
a lot no
but uh you know i tried to get her on
and i think she was just
you know i know you get personal and but
she was fantastic
she got into it she opened up and let go
she's quick-witted she's talented she's
funny she's beautiful
she's erica durants and uh
she's a wife she's a mom she works
really hard she's hard on herself
um i thought i was the only one let's do
it let's
let's get inside erica durants it's my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
all right so first of all it wasn't easy
getting in here you i mean listen i've
had some big
guests and you're a big guest but like
you know i think that you know it was
more like
you don't love doing interviews you're
not like it's not that you don't love
being a team player and you do your
publicity you've always done all that
but it doesn't mean you have to like it
i don't love it
um that's probably obviously nice about
it
i am i you know how you meet people in
the business and they're in the business
for what you get from it versus what you
do in it right i like what's happening
when it when we're on the set
in between action and cut like that's my
favorite or if we have a nice
conversation
but all the other stuff which i know is
necessary like you said i'm a team
player
i try but i don't like live for it some
people
really love it and they're really
talented and they love to get in and do
all that stuff and good for them
do you think that that it's i mean
what's the difference between like
when you're acting right when you're in
a role whether it's smallville
or the arrowverse or saving hope
or all the [ __ ] right all the stuff you
do i mean that not [ __ ] but you know the
[ __ ] the
stuff see we've all done [ __ ]
is maybe my interpretation but yeah okay
i get it well what i'm saying is
when you're uh preparing for a role and
there and it's action
i mean you know you and i deal with some
anxiety and stuff like that we could
talk about that but like
do you get anxiety before an interview
like before this were you going
oh my gosh is he gonna get personal what
is he going to do
i i definitely contemplated here's the
thing um
i have many different personalities
depending on what time of day you get me
or whatever right so
if i geared myself up to finally do
something usually then i put on that
personality if that makes sense the one
that's a little more extroverted a
little more comfortable
doing these things and this is different
because we're friends and i'm talking to
you and
like you're not i'm not looking i know
there's some people are looking for some
hook or whatever
um but this is different because it just
feels like we're sitting and having a
chit chat
okay that's good so because i you know
other people on the show
there's been a couple where uh i'm not
well named dropping because they run the
show but jennifer love he was on the
show a while back
and i remember the first time she was on
she said she had an anxiety attack and
she woke up in the middle of the night
and she's like oh my god michael's going
to ask me about my mother
because she had passed away years ago
and i knew her and and so she was all
worked up before
the interview even started and then you
know then it was great and once you
start we started talking but
you know i wonder about that sometimes
you know if you have a big i i worry
i tend to worry about everything i tend
to worry it's it's like
i wake up and i'll get the clock at 7
7.50 and i'm like oh my god
the the the contractor's gonna be in 30
minutes who gives a [ __ ] why am i why am
i worried about that
why am i uh anxiety ridden
because because it's in anticipation of
oh
i have to get up i have to get a knock
when i start knocking the dogs i gotta
take the dogs out herbs old my dog i
gotta take them to poop all these things
start happening like why are you
i think for myself one of the reasons i
do that is the less that i have
um that's taking me out of myself if
that makes sense if i'm like busy
working all the time i don't have time
really to think about
that but if i'm home then everything has
like if the importance of it is just
overblown and if it doesn't get done i
feel like there's this sense of
failure um so i can get really upset if
i
i made a list of stuff that i'm supposed
to do at the house
and i don't do it right and it's
inconsequential and it doesn't matter
particularly but it's i'm like clinging
to whether i did all the laundry that i
wanted to do that day or i folded it or
what like it's
it gets pretty manic so yeah yeah i'm
trying to find tools to
to manage that but i'm a warrior as well
like i project
way into the future so whether it's with
my kids or with
career or whatever um one tiny little
moment like at a moment with my
five-year-old who
said he was too sick to go to school and
i knew he wasn't too sick to go to
school
but he ended up not going to school and
i just had this
full-on tirade where i was like i got in
the car i was
crying and driving around like a freak
because i was like he can't be weak
i can't set this kid up to think that he
can escape when he wants to
and lie about it and he's going to be 15
and he's going to be jacking around like
it was
completely irrational but yet i kind of
had to go with a wave of it if it makes
sense
yeah you were sort of projecting 25
years from now when he's an
adult as they say in canada not an adult
put the right
prop like seed in his mind right like
you're failing right at that moment
because it's gonna
show yeah that's that's god bless thank
god i don't have kids because i would
really be f
so that's just an example and i'm much
more prone to that anxiety when it comes
to them versus
things for myself yeah and so i noticed
after having them then my anxiety like
just kind of skyrocketed
but you you say like uh you know when
you're working you don't have time to
think about that stuff
but isn't it when you're working too
much then see there's there's this
balance right so when you're not working
you're working intermittently then
everything seems bigger
it's like oh then i have to do this and
it seems like your anxiety's more but
when you're in the
thick of it all when you're working
working working interview uh i could
deal with that because it's
my anxiety is already up there i'm
already into this whole yes
i kind of like it i don't know if you
find that as well i guess we're all
contradictions
walking contradictions but i find that
it's almost as if when i'm working my
brain relaxes does that make sense
that there's so many things to kind of
it's revving at this certain
pace and that's the way it wants to to
work because i'm super super intense
and so when i'm working i can i can
exercise it in a way whether it's with
the dialogue or like you said problem
solving or with it with saving hope it
was fun because i had more of a
leadership role so then i could problem
solve in all sorts of areas and then i
can
deflect all of that away from myself and
i'm not sitting there just sitting
around
thinking but it seems overwhelming to me
like if you're constantly busy and
you're constantly working and doing a
series and now you have three kids
and you have your husband and you have
all these things to like i
can't if you're talking to me while i'm
watching something
if i'm at the computer typing and you go
hey rosenbaum what do you want to get
for dinner
it's like i go i i can't hear anything
you're saying right now
i can't hear you stop wait till this is
over i can't i just get so distracted is
what i'm saying i get distracted
and i can't imagine having children a
family
a i mean i have a dog sick and this and
that and
so there's a there's an element of that
but uh
so how do you do that how do you i don't
know it seems like busier would be worse
no you know i'm weird that way i don't
know if it's because i don't really want
to settle if i settle maybe i think too
much and then
the mood goes from anxious to depressed
is that what happens just keep saying
well you've been with
with david for how many i mean let me
guess let me guess i'm saying
probably
i don't know 15 years we've been married
for 15 and together for almost
well 19 yeah really and i didn't look
that up i
honestly thought about small villain
like when you were about yeah wow
15 years now he's probably seen as you
have him
him his personality changes and things
the things that
just the imbalances the balance is what
you're really strong out what you're
weak at
oh she's sensitive she's gonna freak out
over this oh he's gonna be a dick now
this is kind of like marriage [ __ ] right
well and that's kind of what's cool
about being in a relationship a long
time what's what ends up happening
is um depends on who you are but
sometimes you're married to somebody
that is i think you teach each other
things
you either teach each other things are
you self-destruct i have this theory
that we
now you're now we're going into theories
so good ready
i didn't want to do this will ya
so i have this theory that we are
coming back to earth as you know our own
little spirits and we're supposed to be
learning
as we go and we will constantly attract
ourselves to certain people
to learn lessons from each other it's
like a magnet
and so over the course of our
relationship we've gone from like i have
a tendency to never want to have any
conflict my husband wants conflict
constantly
like if he can find it he'll find it and
i can i will avoid it
so over the course of our relationship
what's interesting is i have gotten more
comfortable with conflict
and he's learning to let go of some
things
that he would not get freaked out about
learning so we actually
kind of helped each other in a way like
not that we're sitting there trying to
judge each other but
it was like that the polar opposites of
our personality actually
helped that makes sense all right well
we're going to get yeah i mean over 20
years a lot of
growing and especially with me i've gone
you know i was in my early 20s and now
i'm in my 40s right so that's a big
change
had kids i've been a lot of different
personalities for david
have you hey you know what i gotta say
that's better than being boring oh the
same girl for
57 years and you're she's saying it's
like erica i'll tell you what i got a
different girl every week
this is fantastic okay you know um
we have this joke uh that there's a
there's a side of me that i use for work
and i i
said this on a silly magazine interview
um
but it's my gemini twin call and i call
her jillian
and she's the one that's more
comfortable with things like this she's
much more outgoing but she's got a bit
of bite and a bit of edge
right so sometimes that's fun and
sometimes it's not fun
well all right well i wanna looking for
all right look
well i want to get in a little bit of
that but first i want to rewind i know
you've talked about it probably but
like you know i i i didn't first of all
i didn't know you were like a trained
singer i don't think i've ever heard you
sing
well that's really a nice way of putting
it i did
like but i stopped training like when i
was 20 right but that was my original
goal
i wanted to be on broadway um and i just
went the wrong direction i went west
instead of east i should have gone to
toronto
but but why can't you do a musical now
wouldn't that be fun challenge to add to
your multiple layers of
erica so this is another thing i do i'll
jump into projects regardless if if
something is new and kind of fun
so right now i'm doing the christmas um
christmas chalet
yeah uh so i did chalet last year and
then i did one called christmas stars
and i got to sing in it i mean it was
super fun and one of the only reasons i
took it is because i got to sing
wait a minute i did see you soon i did
see you singing something it wasn't that
did you sing in something else years ago
this model that's what i remember three
bars like it was just like threesome
i had to audition did you know that i
had to audition for genome you had the
audition for
janeau the director who directed also
jaws too and somewhere in time
he directed a lot of smalls you you
auditioned for what
just to prove that i could sing i had to
sit with shino and jay marshall
james marshall it's j oh my god that's
the worst
these guys are guys if you're listening
james marshall was a producer and
director
on smallville and you know i i love the
guy but we got into it if it's
did you ever see us get into it i yeah i
saw one time
where and of course my reaction to these
things is always to giggle and it's not
because it's a good
situation but that's how i react to
stuff i'm also so
impressed when you do get into things
because i'm not like that so i find it
actually quite fun
but i remember there was one time where
you had i was working with you which i
very rarely do and we were outside
in on the ice and it was [ __ ] cold
and there was uh rain towers
anyways i had just bailed and slipped on
the ice and
i was freezing and then you started
yelling at him and it was totally like
my goal oh yeah i flipped that
oh and he was like do it again and you
were like yeah it was great
i loved it so you're saying i was
sticking up for you i was sticking up
for you
yeah right you're being so great there
you go see sometimes you need but to
sing in front
i had you know sing for something once
and i remember
they uh i think it was from moulin rouge
and uh i had no and i listen i have like
i play music and i record
stuff and i love music and i feel like
you have to take your album you have a
great voice
well thank you it's hard for me to look
look here's the thing i
if you sat with me in the recording
studio like the other night i'm in the
in the in the box and
actually in rob's closet my friend's
closet because we went to capitol
records and recorded and then we had to
go and do some extra little things
and he goes pitchy he'd stop and go
pitchy
it's so stressful he and he and he go
like this he could because he's trained
he's
in his whole life he's like ah and i'm
like okay do it
pitchy you're not hitting the note
you're not hitting the note i'm like
well how do i hit the note smile and i'm
like
hmm he's like i go
and i look like an idiot no one's
watching you just smile when you're
saying the [ __ ]
and i i like why you just want him to
fix it if it's that close well i just
wanted to hit it i wanted to learn but
it's it's
you know i remember i when i auditioned
for it and i went in the direction
it's a big movie you should go in there
and do it i go but i'm not a great
singer or he goes so what just go in
there and i'm
and i and i sang and i was just so
nervous that it could not have been good
they're like okay great
and it but you were like i said a train
singer
can go in there and at least be on pitch
beyond you know be in the right
key know what they're doing not just
right you can do that
well within reason but i do say that the
recording studio is its own beast right
like it's you think that something's and
it's
it's easy to go pitchy right oh yeah
when i was doing my
thing for the christmas stars and as it
is when you do
these kind of shows where um there's not
a lot of time a lot of
not a lot of money great people to work
with but you you're slammed it's not
like you have six months to perfect a
song
right yeah so i flew in and then
the very next morning we were gonna hit
this hit the studio and do our
you know few pieces that we had and um
i actually had to get my co-star who's a
country singer
he had to sit in the thing with me after
a while because i
all of a sudden was forced into a
harmony i didn't think i'd be doing and
then so he was like right here trying to
get me to do the right pitch
as well and i was like and it was hard
even for you
so hard yeah all right go back to juneau
you're in the room with janelle and by
the way i love you know he won't listen
to this but he's this old
little lovable french guy he's got a
little bit of a limp at least he did
when i there and he's got the little
cross eye this cute cross eye
that he don't know if he's looking at
you or not and he's like michael
we have to do this come on you're
goofing around
i don't even know what accident was
doing but i can't say i love you
and one of the things about him is that
he knows he loves women
oh my god like he's got it down to a
science he genuinely loves women without
being
so we were all like everybody was
hugging oh yeah
oh yeah i would flirt with him like when
you can flirt with people
but uh but i i i'd go up to cheneau
and he go good morning michael or
whatever his accent was and i'd go
overnight he's this little man and i
would just give him big
hug he's like okay okay that is good
that's enough let's go
and uh i just loved him but i you know
so go
when you're young when you're working on
you know working when you're on a turkey
farm or some [ __ ] in calgary and you're
growing up in the small town
i mean nobody around you is thinking i'm
gonna go be an actor
i'm gonna go to broadway i'm gonna do
whatever it is you're gonna do
first of all were your parents like did
they ever
do they want you to do something like
that do they want you to do
entertainment or do they expect you to
just be around
always just be around no my mom my mom
was like
the major voice in my head growing up
dad was there he wasn't as
as involved um and he worked really hard
long he was
trucking like when he stopped working on
the farm he was trucking all the time so
it was me and mom
that had all the conversations and so
mom was really big on the
whole idea is that i'm raising you to be
an independent adult whatever you choose
to do
you choose to do it and you'll deal with
the consequences whatever they are
like and it's kind of kind of was great
it was freeing so
um she never said i couldn't do it she
supported it i seemed to love it
and so you know i keep um keep doing it
and she would come and see my plays and
all that kind of stuff
but i was um it's like i didn't fit in
my family
like um my mom goes i had a boy and a
girl in america so like i was the one
that was
now let let me be straight about it like
we're very close
like i love my family but i was kind of
different
and so i don't know where the dream came
from for me to want to do this stuff
whether it was just me hanging out on
the farm and i just remember sitting out
there
and just dreaming big like i was going
to go somewhere and i was going to do
something different and i just wanted to
see the world and
there's all these things that i were you
cliche did you do the cliche thing that
we all do
where you sit back i can just see you
you're on the kent farm but you're in
calgary in your turkey farm
and you're sitting on like the fence and
you're looking up you just saw a
shooting star and you're like
god please please make my dreams come
true
i want to be an actress because i you
know i'm sure i didn't
i just was like please god get me out of
this
please help me get away calgon where the
[ __ ]
are you no you know what it's true but i
would take it one step further
and i often sang like that disney song
that a dream is a wish your heart makes
i would like walk around with the farm
singing it
so did you just a little kid yeah well
well
quite unique were you popular in high
school or were you a school
uh was called i don't think i was
popular
um i found that i had a lot of
contentious relationships with chicks
i got along with the guys well the fact
that you said chicks immediately
i had a contentious relationship with
chicks you know
think about that right there that says
it enough i like [ __ ] chicks
i love that i love that that's awesome
so
growing up i had like a couple of really
cool girlfriends
and then i had just moments i think when
i got into my teens it just was like
weird
because i was hanging out with all the
guys but not in a gross way like they
were always asking me
how to hang out with the other girls or
date the other girls so it's like
i was their friend but then all the
girls in the class thought that
i was a big fat [ __ ] i was stealing all
their boyfriends and i was like i'm
trying to set you guys up
so did you drink were you a boozer in
high school or were you always like a
good people brought a lot to booze
so like i yeah we're not no one's
allowed to build you think
people are allowed to booze when they're
in high school oh you know we're not
allowed to drink
oh well that should stop us but losing
to like
would equal like massive amounts of
sinning
kind of not boozing right so i grew up
in a very very conservative
religious religious farming community
i mean you could peel the onion for a
while with me do you but do
you like do you still go to church do
you still have that influence are you
religious or would you say
uh you're more like well i'm more
agnostic i don't really
necessarily believe in atheists i have
some friends that are atheists like oh
mate he's like [ __ ] you believe in
something come on
that to me that look i respect what
anybody does but atheist to me is a
strong term just like two religious is
too much but it's i would say that i
have a problem with organized religion
sure as if my experiences growing up
doesn't mean that there weren't really
great people there
but to me my reaction to it uh i would
never put my kids in a situation like
that
because um i took verbatim everything
that was said to me and i went to the
extreme so i was one of these kids that
thought they were going to hell every
night
so that's that's the bad part about it
yeah and i just i don't trust organized
religion because
i always wonder where where is your
motivation coming from
is it fear power money you know where
did all the rules come from and so i'm
kind of in that phase of my life where
i'll look
back and um do some studying as to why
say for example they
have certain laws and in christianity
that this is wrong or this is wrong and
then i kind of go
well let's consider what society was
like back then and why they were
motivated to make that as a
one of the ten commandments or whatever
right so i'm kind of
trying to dismantle that for myself a
bit but i
could not live in a world where i didn't
believe in something
that's go ahead and not believe in
anything that's fine for you but i would
find it super depressing
to just think that i die and i want food
i have to believe that i will
see the people i love in another life i
don't know what that's going to be
yeah and no one should take that away
from you and that's that's the purpose
to me it's all about respect if you
don't believe in god
great if you believe in god great i have
friends that are mormons
they're great families they it works for
them they're good people i like being
around them
they're uh you know i have a friend in
indiana who's
who's you know goes to church every
sunday and it works for him and his
family and i'm like that's awesome
you do what works for you it's your life
and for someone else to tell you what to
believe and
what you shouldn't believe in a way so
that's where it gets kind of cloudy so i
always say look
yeah that's the thing about organized
religion and that's why it's i think
it's quite dangerous
um if you look at kind of the the main
belief structure of like all the
different religions that are around it's
mainly
you know you're gonna have to
be responsible for what you do in life
at some point
and let's try to love each other
basically i mean that's a really loose
generalization
but they come together on those couple
of points right
and all the other stuff i think that was
basically
designed for whether it's power or
whatever
right because if you go back and you
study all the different religions oh
that now that one's bad so now that we
can conquer them and kill them all and
make them all this
right so anyways i'm getting heavy no no
and
by the way it's like you can go back
it's a process i don't know if i know
really anything at this point
except for that i think people should
just love each other and like
try to do the best wouldn't that be easy
isn't it easy it's so i talk about this
it's so
there's so much more energy exerted
when you're angry or mean or
you know you have these trolls it's just
like it's so easy to just be like
you know because we all can judge you
know somebody could be walking across
the street and i go what the
[ __ ] is that dude wearing that is t and
i will stop my that is
that is terrible me to judge that is
good for him he's happy let him wear
that look at me i'm gonna
wear a t-shirt and shorts half the time
[ __ ] me so i try to turn it into a
positive because it's like
as long as you're happy yeah it's like
retraining your mind
um whether it's having to do with that
kind of stuff or anxiety or whatever
it's like you catch yourself in that
moment and go
okay i'm projecting into the future i
can be chill
let's live in the moment and ironically
i think that's a little bit of
the covert that's kind of happened to
everybody too with respect to people
obviously
not getting sick but uh or passing away
but the idea that we're forced
kind of into all of us into a time out
where we have to slow down
you know yeah
inside of you is brought to you by geico
how do you not know geico i don't think
of anybody else for insurance
it's the only there's a gun in my head
insurance what do you want
geico yeah how do you not want i mean
it's geico
yeah it's easy to remember it's easy to
remember because
even a rose and bomb can do it uh you
know ryan
you're a renter i'm a renter and it's
the hardest thing to do is just pay your
rent
or for a house it's all the things that
people worry about most
and then there's auto you get insurance
for your car
but with guide code they have bundling
policies
so you could bundle your homeowners or
renters insurance
along with your auto policy and it's
just easy it's geico
easy it's even a rosenbaum can do it
even a rose mom can do it
it's true man you know there's so much
to do around the house and the holidays
and everything and
it's just so easy when it comes to
insurance and making your life easier is
what i'm all about and i'm sure that's
that's how you feel too go to geico.com
get a quote and see how much you could
save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com inside of you is
brought to you
by the awesome magic spoon
listen if you love cereal as a kid and
you're getting older and you can't eat
it because i got all these sugars and
all these things
you have got to listen to me
and check out magic spoon magic spoon
i mean even the covers it feels like
you're a kid again i miss my youth i
miss being able to just
eat cereal and not worry about all this
stuff but then you realize
what all the crap's in and as adults you
know the ducks watch your sugar watch
your this doing this you're getting
and i just love the fact that there's
zero
sugar in these things but it still
tastes great you tried it
it's great it tastes like childhood it
tastes like child it tastes
like childhood 11 grams of protein only
three net grams of carbs
in each servings four flavors cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry
delicious i like that there's just four
flavors they may come up with more
but i like four flavors because when i
go to us i want either
vanilla or chocolate i don't like too
many choices this is all you need right
here
cocoa fruity frosted blueberry it tastes
amazing
honestly too good to be true you have to
try it all my friends
freaking flipped out on this stuff it's
keto friendly it's gluten free for those
people that are like um it's unhealthy i
still can't
no you can keto friendly gluten-free
grain-free
low carb gmo free i don't know how it
tastes good but it does
go to magicspoon.com iou
to grab a variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code
iou at checkout to get free
shipping and magic spoon is so confident
in their product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money
no questions asked come on that's
magicspoon.com
iou and use the code iou
for shipping we thank magic spoon for
sponsoring the podcast when i picture
you as this young girl
singing that disney song hoping that the
scene
yeah to yourself which ones you know
everybody has their stories in jim
carrey i wrote myself a 10 million
dollar check and then i
cashed it one day yeah whether that's
true or not it's a nice
of music to the cows they loved me what
was the big song and sound of music
um oh god i got a smile sorry
all right smallville i didn't really
know you because again we didn't work a
lot together
but when we did i noticed something
about you which i've talked to you about
which was you had anxiety like i do
in different ways i tend to
[Music]
fake it i have this confidence where i
could turn into a confident guy you the
god this guy's so confident [ __ ] what
an
[ __ ] like i'm so i'm throwing it at
you so you don't think there's any like
you know
yeah but i do suffer and i would suffer
by
you know always doubting myself and
always like you're not good enough and
like did the director like you did the
other actors like you are you good are
you gonna keep your job
it was this constant cyclical maniacal
[ __ ] thing that just
was just pounding in my head and so for
me i would do my thing now
you i noticed you were the sweet version
but you weren't like someone that was
just like hey chicks
i'm about to do my scene you know what's
up chicks you were
you were sort of like you were sort of
um what's the word uh
tentative no what's the word is that the
right word sort of like uh uh what's the
word
i would go really introverted so
uncertain
uncertain i constantly second-guess
myself i don't know where that's
from but actually i'm actually working
on that
actually at this point in my life which
is crazy to say at you know 42 i'm like
i'm really
learning to trust myself and walk away
and not constantly be going well that
wasn't good enough that wasn't good
enough though i don't know
that's what i remember you were sort of
apologetic you were always like i'm
sorry i'm you know
well here's what's baffling if you they
would have said action and erica
durants was terrible then i would have
been like well she
i guess that's why she's nervous because
she's just not very good but you were so
good that i didn't understand why you
were so uncertain on all these things
which i also looked at myself and said
wow sometimes i'd watch you know i
didn't watch all the time but when i
watched myself i'd go
i was able to actually say
you were good dude you're good in this
sometimes
i well hang on me to myself and then yet
you'd think that when i got back on set
i'd be confident and ready to
but it wasn't always like that it was
always always this perpetual doubt
this sort of like why am i doing this to
myself why am i getting anxiety again i
know i'm good i know i can do this
and there's that feeling that you have
to be good there's more people around
there's this
and i hate that and some therapists will
say this is what drives you this is what
makes you better i go i don't want to
punish
myself and they say then quit i'm like
well if i quit then i've given up i want
to conquer my fears i want to be
able to just be you know like everybody
so yeah back to you i just want that's
how i felt so how did you feel
um i couldn't believe i was there right
like i felt like i had joined a group of
like the cool kids
and the ones that have done all these
great things in the world and then there
was me
that just kind of randomly showed up on
the set you have to understand
i used to book tom and kristen's photo
double on that show you were captured
you were casting director yeah so all of
a sudden i'm
in the show i'm working on the show and
it's halfway through and i know it's
really popular and that sort of thing so
i just always felt um
a little bit behind and like i was off
off kilter a bit
um and that yeah like i was a big dork
and didn't quite fit in
and you could tell because i would do
these weird things and people like that
is really bizarre
um i didn't think you were weird at all
i just thought you were just a little
nervous which is fine
but now as you're talking it's really
dawning on me like i'm imagining myself
and maybe you guys out there could do
this imagine yourself
talking about casting someone a movie
and you're just you're sitting there
you're eating chips
and you're like how about this girl or
how about this guy okay i'll cast him
that's great and then someone goes
you know why don't you play the role
what you're gonna play you're gonna be
in smallville
what yeah and it was like i remember
because i got it on a friday and then i
had to do my read with
tom i we've talked about this because
you know people are always asking that
question
but i didn't realize that he was really
gracious about it but i didn't realize
that that was like if he hated me
i would not have the job and i'm glad i
didn't know that i would have been so
stressed i know tom you're not gonna see
me stressed i would have been like i
can't even speak
i don't know i mean honestly tom
probably would have gone
um just not attracted to her i i bet
like think about it like honestly if you
don't have chemistry with someone
and they're supposed to be lois lane to
your clark kent
it's not chauvinist what's the whatever
to just say just say the producers you
know what i'm not feeling it i don't
feel like the chemistry in the uh
or what you're saying is you're not
attracted to the person like you know
immediately when you meet
an actor i think there are two types of
actors there are the ones that
are cool like us oh yeah the words
though
but you know right away when you meet a
certain actor and you're like okay we
just won't get along we're going to be
like oil and water
and that's just the way it is because we
view it so differently
and so i think that that's part of what
happens when you initially meet with
people
um and so maybe that was what ended up
happening in that read or whatever
because i remember beeman was there and
i was so stressed out and i had to read
my scene and i was like
oh my god um so
well what was your first line on small
do you remember it
or first i think oh gosh do you know
what
it was like i came out of the elevator
all i remember is i came out of the
elevator and walked down the hall i was
going to find chloe in the hospital
and it wasn't clark it was nathaniel
it was like half naked looking the other
way
i never remember nathaniel was the
standard right nathaniel did it was such
a pose and tom doesn't focus at all
nathaniel the stand-in was uh so he's
shirtless
he's shirtless and then a little
something else on the back i don't
remember so you saw a butt cheek
like a half crack i think so okay and
this is the standard not tom standing in
for tom welling
and he's posing when you say pose what
was he posing like what was he was he
doing a superman flop
as one would i think try when they're
gonna be naked try to look good
but nathaniel also was quite theatrical
so it was just quite funny because
the two different people could have been
welling you'd have been like
are you done you know but uh
nintendo was enjoying it and i remember
i just walked in
and i don't remember that day at all
like i was so scared but i know lois
said something quippy
and then the next scene we did i
remember specifically
because it was some other time that i
saw clark naked isn't that great that's
how they
introduced my character onto the show
good for you and i go i'm lois lois lane
i remember that line did you think that
your anxiety
and maybe depression really smallville
was the reason for that because there
was so much pressure and so much stress
and anxiety
to come on that show that that kind of
pushed it into a different direction
from that
do you blame small people for your
anxiety or did you like honestly because
like i remember i worked i worked i
worked i stressed i stressed i stressed
and then something was the
the tipping point something what that
got me over the edge where i'm like okay
now i have uh
anxiety that i can't really control as
easy as i used to be able to
i'm older now this has happened i've
gotta take a step back
and was it smallville or was it
something or did you always deal with it
it's always been part of my personality
but i didn't recognize it
for what it was and so it wasn't small
actually i got a lot from small but
pushed me out of out of
um myself right um
and i learned to trust myself a little
bit more and then as i went into saving
hope i really was
thrown into the deep water myself um and
and then you really start to kind of
keep your own counsel and go it's good
enough and you kind of move on right
i never really believed that there was
something like that that would happen to
me that i would actually get to do the
acting thing for real
right i was fully ready to kind of
continue on as everybody else i knew
went on and
completely fine with it right so when it
came about it just surprised me
and then took me a while to get my feet
under me but i loved it so much
um i think my anxiety and depression
came out after my second kid
and it was that's where it kind of got
triggered is that postpartum
yeah and i've never well i'm i'm
managing it much better but
the it really i don't know body
chemistry
what it was but when i when i went to
have
lachlan my five-year-old we had to do
lots of ivf we did quite a few years of
that
and so when you do that you really play
with your hormones a lot
and that can kind of affect all sorts of
things that can affect how you look how
you feel
but it can be forever like then your
your hormones are out of whack for a
really long time
and some of them don't really go back
right so if you think about all that
stuff that you're pumping through you
the only thing that i can kind of liken
it to and i don't know if you've ever
done this in your life and you don't
have to say
but when i try to explain it to a man i
say
have you ever done taken extra
testosterone to work out or have you
ever done a little bit of caffeine or
have you ever
and it gets that kind of rager and the
rager comes out
that's kind of like some of the the
hormones that i did only lasted for like
15 months right jesus so i
now when i look back on like how busy it
was how tired i was i was
i had two pregnancies while i was
working um
i was trying ivf for 10 years like so
i think it all just kind of went to the
point and then i had my second son
and then saving hope was done then and
it was just like everything stopped
right i've been working for 15 16 years
and
and then it stopped and i had nothing
else to do and then i have
all these hormones and these emotions
right and i think that it just kind of
you know what i love that you're so
honest about that because that's so
important for people to hear not only
for women to hear it but for men to hear
it because
you know i i've said this before and you
know
it's way [ __ ] harder to be a woman
it's so obvious
the [ __ ] that you guys go through and
then you're having periods and then
giving birth and then all the hormones
and the [ __ ] it's just it's just not
even on the same
[ __ ] level ever then you start to get
as women then you start to get okay
after having your kids and you think
everything's gonna go fine
and then you go into uh menopause and
everything gets [ __ ] how does
menopause start
it depends on the person my mom started
really early so i might be
starting in my 40s somewhere she started
at 39 that's how powerful she was she
was like i'm done
and she like set her body into menopause
just by sher willpower
but um it really messes with you like i
have so many girlfriends that are a
little bit older than me
and they're going through it right now
and it's like
they're [ __ ] so angry and so stressed
and
so depressed and it's all these emotions
that are going by the postpartum i just
never really understood it i never
because i'm a guy and then um my friend
nate
years ago uh he had a baby and um
his mom terry calls me one day you know
southern woman
love her call her mom she's like hey
mike uh
amy's gone and i said what terry what
uh we lost amy and i go
what what do you mean nate's wife
she oh overdosed on pills to a bottle
singapore
[ __ ] postpartum and it's such a serious
thing
that was a huge wake-up call where i was
like this woman wasn't suicidal this
woman wasn't
like wanting to take her life this is
postpartum is a
real thing and she
and they i don't know they weren't on
top of it or she was too shy or too
reserved to
want didn't want anybody to know that
she was having these feelings
and these and for whatever reason she
took about and then didn't wake up and
it was the most heart and i had to fly
to indiana and i stayed with nate a week
and i was on baby duty at like one
three and five to change the diapers and
i'm like what the f
and just hanging out with him and and
going this is just
awful so uh yeah i don't know why i felt
compelled to tell that story
um if you're okay extrapolating on that
i don't know if you want it to be like a
happy or like a
like my is this okay for the podcast
yeah no i mean this is real [ __ ] man
okay so
one of the things about i found about
postpartum is is like in hindsight when
you look back you realize that wasn't
quite normal
like i don't even think a lot of times
unless women have read about it
beforehand
and have support they don't really know
that they have it they don't know
they're just
living in it so one of the major things
that women
that i've talked to and myself felt was
when i had my children i had a panic
because i realized i wasn't going to be
alone in my head ever again
there was always going to be a person
there and that freaked me out and not
only was it a person it was a person
that i felt
i didn't deserve to take care of and
there's a lot of women
that experience that they think
if it would be actually they really
think this because i remember thinking
this clearly and i
remember thinking it was loving it would
be easier
if i wasn't around than for me to be
around and [ __ ] because i was so
terrified
that i was gonna mess them up and they
were so perfect
that i thought but it's better that
somebody else that's more calm and that
could do this right would be around than
me
and i just wanted to disappear and
i seem like a completely logical thing
completely logical
like this is a loving choice that i'm
making so i'm not going to put on
what you know what happened to that
woman but they really like it's not out
of a selfishness it's out of the sense
of like i can't
i'm going to hurt you i'm going to wreck
you you're perfect i understand
honestly i wha what you just said
absolutely resonates
it is probably what most parents feel or
mothers
feel to a certain degree i mean
certainly some are meant to be absolute
mothers and want to give birth
the second they can you know and some
don't and some weight and some are act
you know they well i hate to
use the word accidents they're all
miracles little miracles um
but the biggest fear i have and this
on another level of course throwing it
back to me but in a way that i can
understand or make you understand that i
understand you
is that i think part of the reason maybe
i didn't you know i haven't become a
father i always scares me i'm like well
who's going to
teach the kids math i know it sounds
funny who's going to teach the kids
science
i i'm going to fail i'm going to fail
this kid i'm going to [ __ ] up i'm going
to i'm going to ruin this kid's life i
can't do this like
it's almost like it's it's what are you
doing yeah of course you could do this
but you get start imagine and now
amplify that
by actually being a woman who's giving
birth to this child and
so i can't even imagine it's it it is uh
i absolutely understand what you're
saying
that makes perfect sense where you're
like i i can't do this i'm going to fail
this person so it's
easier for me to go it's the enormity of
like and that's we talked we're
going full circle if if you can have
somebody in your life that's supporting
you and with you
which is not really usual in you know
like western culture to have like
the mother and the auntie and this
person that person to kind of go
let's not project into the future let's
just do today yeah like if somebody
just said let's just do today let's not
project into like
what they might do when they get older
or how you're gonna
i remember this was my intensity factor
i don't know if i've told you this but i
remember
there was a time that i i freaked out
and i yelled and lachlan was only about
like 16 months old so not very old and i
just had a total freak out
and i looked over and i'd never seen
that look in his eyes
and my first thought was oh my god i'm
the person that taught my son to be
afraid
like that's the first thing i thought
and i thought i can't do this i can't be
around i'm gonna wreck him
and so like anyways i'm again
super super intense right right well
you know what isn't it easy to i mean
think about that
i can remember children remember i
remember
it's weird because you remember a lot of
the bad things don't you
you remember things that are like you
know i'll say things that this happened
but if you asked my parents about it
they're like what are you talking about
and i'm like no
this is exactly how it happened i'm the
kid
i remember it that's how because it's
how i felt they might not have thought
that that was causing that
they thought oh we were just fighting i
had an axe in my hand i wasn't gonna
really kill your mother
like what you know but a little
foreplay but it's amazing the things so
but then you start to think logically
and it's hard to think that way but
you're like
i am gonna say things and make him think
oh my god i'm crazy or
i'm scared or i'm this this is just this
is part of it you can't be perfect in
front of your son
always and it's hard to accept that
because you will [ __ ] up constantly if
you're trying to be too safe
you're just killing yourself by the way
you've had four hairstyles in this
interview i know
and i like them all it's gonna go back
up
i i like them i'm not you know what i'm
i wish i was casting something because i
have four looks now
and uh there's no description it's not
moving if you saw my feet
how does she look with her hair up uh
could we can you bring her back for a
read i'd like to see your hair up
can we uh yeah i get so squirmy no
you're great
um you think oh that's going to be where
he went
by the way this is i love i'm not just
saying this uh you know
i know you're a little bit like maybe a
little nervous about it
you know like i don't because we had to
sort of cancel once because you're like
i don't know if i could do this because
you know it's me and it's like
and i go yeah you know and then i asked
you again and you're like you know what
fine let's do it
and but you weren't you weren't mean you
were i i got it
and i l but but i'm loving this is what
i'm saying okay good
me too it's fun it is it's i i'm just
learning so much i mean i didn't think
we'd talk about these things and it's
like i really think
that a lot of people are gonna relate to
this or they're gonna especially the
the the issues that you're talking about
with postpartum or rings i
just these things it just i know that
usually it's like
therapy for me and if it's there for me
therapy for me it's probably therapy for
some people out there
um oh yeah arrowverse when they asked
you to do aeroverse
what was that like what was that like
going on because how long had it been
since you acted with tom
or were lois lane i mean i guess well no
because you weren't lois lane on
supergirl you were
i hadn't seen walling for like well
since we ended
when did we end yeah something like that
yeah
yeah so nine years were you nerd was it
weird was it just weird jumping into
that character
it was like yeah it was very very
comfortable
and easy and it was like fun i loved it
did you get a good response from it
i think everybody was pretty excited
about it that you know
um i usually don't pay attention to a
lot of trolls so maybe it's a skewed
reaction right but i know that people
are really excited about it
being part of the the arrowverse again
i am i wish it had been a little bit
longer but then in a way it's great that
it was
sure because then you know you get in
get out and
yeah for sure well what about what about
like when you did supergirl
and you played you played her mom right
yeah there's no way you look like her
[ __ ] mom
well i am getting a little long in the
tooth as one would say
but i belong in the two kid at 10 years
old
so this will launch a whole other
session of podcast
but we can do another time because it's
been so much fun but um
it's funny to go from like kind of like
ingenue
and then they don't know what to do with
you so then you just become a mom
and i am a mom it's fine but like
melissa's 31.
was it was it fun or was it boring or
was it it was okay
you know what it felt like being back on
smallville but not with my
buddies right like everybody was nice
melissa was super cool
but it it felt so strange because it was
a bit like small though all the
all the sets were like that and all of
the stunts were like that you know
was it as fun i mean in terms of like
the set was it
it wasn't really my family right like i
felt like although it was my family it
was a new family
i'll have fun um i just found myself
i took my earphones and stuff because
you know what ends up happening right
like if you're on the show a long time
you get to kind of choose your little
space where you go sit
if you're guesting you sit where they
put the bloody chairs
so sometimes i'd be sitting in there and
then they're like trying to have they're
having their conversation i'm sure
they're not even
registering me at all which is fine but
i just felt like i was like
in their space do you know what i mean
so i just like put my earphones on to
read my book
okay like retweeted back into erica but
you you enjoyed it it was just like so
what i'm gathering is this because this
makes perfect sense
so as an actor when you come on a set
and you're a guest star
or you're just recurring or whatever it
is the hardest job in the world
you are like imagine smallville we're
established i know
sort of what i'm doing kind of we're all
it's a machine
and then all of a sudden erica durants
as lois lane
jumps into the machine she's on set for
the first time
and as a guest or as a guest star at
this point we don't know she walks out
of the elevator and sees a naked
stand-in
this is her first day on [ __ ] set and
it's like
how do you feel comfortable so when
erica's talking about
supergirl it's not that she didn't like
it or whatever but she's
also doesn't belong in their family that
doesn't belong but she's not
she's just kind of there and like she's
not part of this really and so that is
very difficult yeah was your anxiety
through the roof
no no not at all i don't know why i was
just like whatevs maybe i was still like
i just i was only
maybe i'm getting old i like that you're
like
less anxiety i love when i when i'm
taking things in stride and i'm like
maybe you thought lois lane big i got to
be great i'm nervous anxiety
mom huh let's just do it whatever
it's just like i have like zero horses
in this game
i just came in i did my purple alliance
okay this is [ __ ] talking with erica
durants folks uh your questions this is
uh rapid fire okay oh i'll try not to
think too hard about my answer though
these are from my patrons uh
thank you for supporting the podcast and
erica will love hearing these questions
carly t loved you as lois lane when you
took on the roll
were there any conscious decisions you
made to make your lowest different from
the ones that came before you
no honestly i didn't i didn't compare
myself to the other people i was
i was sliding down that water slide
going okay this is my material this is
my material and
you just read it memorized it delivered
it and that's me
that's it oh and i hope i used to say
you just throw a bunch of [ __ ] at the
wall and see what sticks
it was dynamic yeah you were dynamic
lisa h on a recent online convent
convention panel you had mentioned that
before you landed the part of louis and
smallville you actually worked for
talent agency
how was the transition this is a good
question because we talked about how was
the transition from
an administrative position to being the
talent
and how fast did that happen uh it was
it was weird it was bizarre like i said
sometimes it would make me more nervous
because i was on the set and i knew all
the background and i was like i gotta
perform
so if there's more background people
there i was much more uncomfortable than
if it was just like
a scene with another actor because you
were thinking oh my god she casts us and
she's doing
it it's not like everybody's watching
even though you and i both know they
couldn't give a [ __ ]
but they're just like hurry up i want
lunch please hurry this guy can't
deliver his [ __ ] line lex loser is
supposed to be brilliant the guy can't
even get his lines out
jennifer ann what is your favorite
episode of smallville with tom willing
as clark kent
my favorite season i don't have favorite
episodes because they're all the same
but i like season eight a lot but that's
also because i would
in the other seasons leading up to it i
was always the
joke at the end of the scene so i would
show up at the end of a scene that i
thought was
about something interesting and then i'd
say something and then the scene would
be over so
nico p who's your favorite sports team
to root for let me guess the calgary
flames
and uh i like the seahawks seattle
seahawks
that's close to calgary that's only an
hour from calgary right or no couple
all right dana s with how the world has
changed so much how are you dealing with
schooling with the kids
wine liquor or beer
um edibles oh pot edibles
something mellow that just do you feel
like alcohol makes me
really mean mommy
that's enough when my husband would walk
in and i had my vodka bottle out of the
freezer and i was just drinking and he
was like oh
[ __ ] did you both laugh or was it like a
moment he was like wow
yeah it's just a sip i've been caught
doing that honestly i feel like an
alcoholic but i'm like
i don't drink really so once i got
caught drinking out of the bottle and
they're like are you serious dude i go
okay i know what this looks like this is
the first time i've ever done i just
sound guilty there's nothing to say
but it really was i don't do that so
anyway well see that's what makes me a
little bit more like
i kind of i'm like a dude like it's just
easier to drink it on a bottle than get
a class
i do that all the time my friends are
like can i drink the lemonade nope
how about the diet coke nope cause i
drank out of it
i do that all the time i don't waterfall
it either like it's so full on
yup shelby is there a character you'd
love to play in a movie or tv show is
there something you'd love to do
something with music i love that vinifia
new patreon what is your favorite thing
about life that's a great ender what's
your favorite thing about life
recently i would say that that it's
gonna change
and i love that whether it's that it
forces me to live a little more in the
moment and also feel a little bit less
desperate if things are rough there's
always
there's always a change there's always a
balance to the to the negatives
and family you know what i like to be
about life
being alive that's a good thing
i mean you know what it's like that's i
know it sounds stupid but honestly the
fact that you're
you're actually able to talk and walk
hair change now i'm thinking again
deeply this is erica this is real erica
i love really getting into chatting with
a friend of mine and then
i look and i think my face looks really
round and then i take my hair
by the way this is this has been really
fun if we ever do another podcast
because we're running out of time for
your session we can talk about something
that was
really tough in my life that i had to do
if we ever do another podcast well can
you give me a hint about it
it's when i did the hard stern show oh
wait wait wait
you did the howard stern show well it
was one
i ended up doing it twice and i
shouldn't have gone back but what was it
what
he was just asking you like because it's
howard he asked personal questions
um so the first time was kind of gross
but i got away with it
and then i did a butterfly effect two
and i got a lot of pressure from the
studio and from a lot of people to go on
hearthstone my first
reaction was and this is what i should
have stuck to no
it's not my it's not my deal like my
life isn't that like that i don't have a
toddler existence it's fairly basic
um but then they kept asking and asking
in the studio's like you got to do this
and so i said okay i'll go and do this i
can do this
because the last experience i had with
howard he's a nice enough guy like he's
smart he knows his
stuff you just have to know what you're
doing when you go in the ring with him
and i did not and so they they do these
pre-interviews with you where they ask
you something so they gave me this
line of making up these like
west van parties that that our family
does which is like
we're known for like west van is known
for swinging and all that
jazz and all that west vancouver west
vancouver yeah
i don't know the group and i i don't
understand why it happens but i don't
judge
okay anyways pre-interview they said
make this [ __ ] up and then we'll segue
we'll have a little laugh and then we'll
segue into talking about your show
and so i did that and then they didn't
let it go and there was no way i could
get around it it got worse and worse and
worse as i was sitting there
and then then they started making fun of
my outfit
and saying i looked amish they're just
trying to get any kind of
reaction out of me this is on the actual
show yeah this is on the show like if
you youtube and now a bunch of people
might use it so howard's interviewing
you
howard's interviewing me and and they're
making fun of you
oh yeah because they realized that it
wasn't me
like i was trying to play this game if i
had been like them and gone in there
and known how to like work the room and
stuff they probably would have chilled
but the worst experience of that and i
cannot believe i didn't birth
i don't know why i didn't leave but he
had two cronies
that threatened they were standing there
off camera
and they were going to drop trowel and
show me their business to try to get
another reaction out of me
like it was just a nightmare and all i
could think is
i've like brought so much shame to my
family and that's all i could think
about was like
why did you do this if it had just been
me i would have been like that was
really embarrassing and dumb
but i felt so embarrassed for my family
because it was so tawdry
and um well wait a minute but you were
on his show before we talked about it to
kristen and that's it well you were on
on the show on tower stream once before
you said
yeah and that was fine well it was okay
it was still like kind of embarrassing
and it was time
but it was okay enough for you to come
back so you felt like it wasn't gonna
get
i felt like it was gonna be like kind of
like the soft footing it right and
something light and joke and then talk
about the movie i was supposed to get on
there and talk about the movie and they
wouldn't do it right they couldn't let
go of this
ridiculous story that they told me to
make up
and um and i just couldn't figure out a
way to get out
and it was over and howard was really
nice like he came up afterwards he's
like are you okay you seem like
like i think they thought it was part of
their show right
and and i'm like yeah yeah yeah and i
got out of there
and i went downstairs and i started like
i was bawling in the room
in the building below and somebody
reported that back
and then it was like headlines erica
left howard stern crying and
like it's taken me this has been well
over a decade 15
16 years to even talk about it because
it was so embarrassing
you know what but it's good to talk
about it now and especially in this
world where we're talking about
our past and it's like you know what i
still learn something valuable
from that like go with your gut and if
you can't do something or you don't
think you should or it's not your deal
like don't be so afraid of authority
just say no
and i have a hard time saying no if my
boss says i'm supposed to do something
right
yeah especially if they're not like
maybe you weren't prepared enough
obviously or
you know and i know i don't think you
know when i've listened to howard stern
i don't think you know and i was always
a huge fan i was always dying to get on
the show i guess i was never big enough
obviously
to be on the show but i always used to
love howard and he used to talk about
smallville and
you know yeah he was and he was great
and
so i don't i don't picture him like i
think that like he had no idea that you
were
probably that's what you said you were
like i don't think he didn't know that i
was really upset
and so because you could fake it pretty
good you're you're strong enough you're
like yeah but and then you're
you're dying inside like oh it was
brutal and how long was it how long was
the interview
it felt like it was like four hours long
it was probably 20 minutes
but it was just like oh my god
and so now i look at those things in my
life and i try to say okay what would
what would i say in response to that it
was interesting i was talking to kristin
about it and i still felt like it was
all my fault and kristen's like
you know in scenarios like that it isn't
all your fault
like they shouldn't have been
threatening to show you their penises
like that's not okay isn't that amazing
how that many years ago how many years
ago was that 10 years ago
more than that i was like 26 maybe 27.
i mean obviously now everything's
changed that wouldn't even none of that
would fly
you know and now it's always been able
to get away with whatever and he's just
you know
again i'm not here actually to diss
howard oh i knew it was his show
what i learned from looking at it now is
that i just don't do something that's
not
true to me right right but i don't know
how many young people
men we always talk about women
specifically but i'm sure there's a
similar idea with men like if you look
at yourself in your early 20s
were there things that you did because
you were younger and you just wanted to
like i think that's a human thing yeah
sometimes i believe with women sometimes
it goes into a more sexualized realm
or something that feels a little bit
worse maybe perhaps or more vulnerable
but i i haven't talked to an actor yet
male or female that
doesn't look back on their 20s and go
yeah you just can't you can't like i i
just think it's really hard unless you
were
you know if you say oh you know in your
early 20s you know you were at clubs and
you were
you know hanging out with women and you
were like i'm like
look what you were doing we evolved we
changed it's not like i was killing
animals in my twenties
yeah it's not like i uh well i murdered
someone but i
that was 30 years ago so
i'm not a murderer
um look i love that you're so honest
about this and um
man i yeah i want you will you come back
promise me you'll come back okay yeah
this is so easy and it's like you you're
you are so open about like
you'd be surprised like people come on
and they're like i don't think they're
going to talk about anything and then
people just open up and
whether they do or not i mean when they
do it's just they realize how many
people out there
like that yeah anyway i don't want to go
on but you're really good at making
people feel comfortable though
well because i'm so uncomfortable we're
having a conversation just the two of us
and i think that that takes skill to be
able to do that as a host
some don't have that and that's where
people become aware of themselves a
little bit more and
start censoring themselves more i think
yeah well i appreciate that i
you know i think in the beginning i was
always trying to like i just want them
to be here i just want to be
and now i feel like i do forget that i'm
doing i feel like i'm just talking to
you a lot of time until i look at ryan
wearing a [ __ ] mask across from me
and i'm like oh there's ryan we're in a
[ __ ] podcast room this isn't real
are you in your cool uh studio with all
your fun it's just a little it's a
little bedroom that i made into a
podcast room a little couch and little
posters everywhere and
um you know all that stuff my office is
like that i have all my old like
i have a couple of cool old small little
posters
which i got everybody to sign and then
remember we were at the convention and
we took a
a group photo yep i framed that with a
bunch of other stuff and it looks really
cool because there's our old photo
like the poster where everybody's like
thinking they're so sexy oh yeah and
then there's less of the
it's cool i will say this in closing um
that all those shots where i had to pose
with tom and kristen
and those are the hardest days because
you're around
two natural beauties and i'm not saying
this to be self-deprecating
i am around two tens and i'm
if you add personality and
like charisma maybe to my looks i'm up
to maybe a
seven if you add the you know but but
they're tens i could be a sixer
definitely that's what you're saying
well dax always says he goes yeah you
and i
are like uh we're solid eights cause
we're uh
you know we're what do you say our looks
are a
six and our personalities are a tense so
we're a solid
eight dude but anyway what i'm trying to
say it was those were the hardest shots
to be sexy it's like how could i be sexy
around them i guess i just have to
hope that a picture comes out that um
but those were like i was like [ __ ]
i guess i'll do my best i'm not supposed
to be that hot anyway i think
that's part of getting on the show for
me as well i was just like
with the two of those people come on no
you no but there's a difference there's
a huge difference
i would beg to differ like about i think
that
there's kristen and tom and they look
like they came out of a drawing all
right
you know what this is by the way we're
saving this because this is the next
time we talk we're going to start with
this
okay okay i should stop talking then no
we're going to start with this
we are going to i want to start with
this conversation because people oh i
want to hear more about that because i
want to talk about how it is
how hard it is working with beautiful
people all right listen i love you and
we're doing this again
and uh this will all be edited
by oh i love you
i loved it i love the stuff about howard
stern
yeah i love the stuff i love her opening
up she's uh
she's a really good person you could
tell she's got a big heart and
uh he's canadians man these canadians
they're all like
you just i'm so jealous of these
canadians you got a lot of good
canadians these canucks
these canucks you know what canuck is i
do canadian vancouver canuck
that's right the vancouver canucks or
canadians i mean canuck is another word
for it
so thank you erica for coming on the
podcast hopefully you enjoyed that we
got some great guests a great guest
coming up too uh before the end of the
year
and the new year we've got some really
great guests as well so we'll be
announcing those but
um i hope you guys are gonna join us
next year and uh all the fun things we
have lined up
and uh remember stages we are doing
stage it's the last saturday of every
month live music
songs with me my buddy rob our band
sunspin
and uh follow me on stage it go to
stageit.com and type in michael rosemont
follow me and i'll let you know when
we're having a show and also on the
social
you'll know but again um please write a
review
please rate the show uh go to apple
podcast or whatever and uh subscribe
all right uh here's the patron shout out
again thank you to all the patrons if
you want to join it's a great thing
and i can't thank you guys enough uh
there's certain tiers uh you get merch
boxes every three months with
uh i write special notes and um
some tiers get to ask [ __ ] talking
questions to the guests and there's
inside of me where you ask me questions
and i do these funny things where i
dress up as other characters
and a lot of other great stuff and um
also when i
eventually get this camp thing going
camp rosie
i'm asking my patrons first they get
first dibs on camp
i'm going to do a uh like a big fun camp
i've talked about it and i you know so
there you have it
uh here we go nancy d does that ring a
bell
okay leah s trisha f sarah v little lisa
you kiko
jill e bryant h uh lauren g
nico p and zachary
robin asked jerry w emily k robert i
jason w stephen j kristen
k not to be confused with kristen crook
correct amelia oh allison l
jess j lucas m raj
c joshua d we got emily s cjp we got
samantha m jennifer and jackie p
stacy l carly h jennifer s janelle b
carey b
tab of the 272 not to be confused with
73 ashley ryan kimberly e crystal h
mike e marissa and jack s that's slater
ramirez beth b oh sassy beth b
sassy beth b santiago
m sarah f chad w leanne p
russian r a maya p maddie s tiffany i
kendrick f
ashley e margie m shannon d
matt w belinda and i want to see belinda
narlyl
so you can remember her name linda
carlile belinda will that help you
kevin v james r chris h a new should w
uh josh b
gabby m dave h samantha s spider-man
chase
correct sheila g yep ray h
alyssa c tabitha t misha h deb
a tom and natalie 6 22 not to be
confused with it
allie b naught's gonna be confused with
ellie g
correct susan b henry s katie f
daniela v liliana a joseph c michelle k
maddie wags marcus w marcus
some new people fun i appreciate you
thank you so much for uh supporting the
podcast
i hope you're enjoying patron patreon
and all my patrons just when we got
newcomers
make them feel welcome make them feel i
can't wait to have that party too i'm
gonna have a patreon party someday
and we just gotta wait obviously now is
not the right time
you don't say no it's not the right time
uh by the way happy holidays to
everybody happy hanukkah if you're a jew
if you're not happy
whatever i have a christmas tree
it's not as big this year because i'm
alone for the most part i got my dogs
some joy in the house yeah there's some
joy yeah yeah that's nice got your
menorah out too
did you see the menorah good yeah i
haven't lit in the menorah litten
litten i haven't lit no i haven't laid
in a menorah
for about oh say 12 years
yeah no i i lit one and i said the
prayer i had to look it up and i was
like
you know i'm gonna try and do a nice
thing and i'm not religious but you know
it's like hey
you know just saying a prayer and you
know saying thanks
lord yeah thanks if you believe in god
if you don't but you know
i love all of you and i hope you had fun
today and i hope you enjoyed erica
because i sure did
and uh make sure you follow us and all
that stuff and uh thank you all of my
patrons again and all the listeners out
there and uh come back will you
thanks uh to my buddy ryan here yep
thanks to bryce thanks to westwood one
thanks to uh that's it thanks to all of
you thank you for allowing me to be
inside each and every one of you
uh from ryan and myself here in the uh
podcast room in my
house we love you play some christmas
music ryan
is there any free christmas music is
there one of them is going to be public
domain i'll find it oh this one
oh yeah this one this is a good one
all right all right cool we're just like
oh holy night